[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلها بابرس
العناوين
[موسيقى]
كيف تتوقعوا ربيعا شرسا للحرب
للدبابات بعيدا عن المانيا
الغرب يعمق عقوبات على ايران بسبب القمع
وتحذيراته من اقتراب امتلاك طهران للقنبله
النوويه
من يحاول استغلال الازمه واللعب على اوجاع
الناس واحتياجاتهم
وفي العراق
السوداني يمهل المحافظ الجديد للبنك
المركزي ثلاثه اشهر
المدارس السريه تتحدى طالبان الفتيات
الافغانيات يوصلن التعليم رغم الحظر
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من ملف الحرب في
اوكرانيا حيث تتوقع الاستخبارات في اكياس
قتالا شرسا في لوجان سكودانياس خلال شهري
فبراير ومارس اتوقع جاء بناء على معلومات
سريه تقول كيف انها حصلت عليها وتفيد بان
الرئيس
مشيره الى ان الجيش الروسي بدا بالفعل في
تغيير تكتكاته العسكريه
بالحصول سريعا على الدبابات الغربيه
لاحداث الفارق ضد نظيرتها الروسيه على
الارض
الدبابات الثقيله راس الحربه في اي هجوم
او دفاع توفر مستوى عاليا جدا من الحمايه
ضد اسلحه النيران المباشره
تساعد في التحرك بسرعه على الطرق
والتضاريس الوعره تعمل على الاتجاهات
الحاسمه وخرط المناطق المحصنه والنفاذي
عمق العدو
تعد القوه الضاربه الاهم في القوه
العسكريه لاي جيش
تنفذ عمليات والتطبيق وشاطر دفاعات العدو
وتدميرها
تمتلك قوه اختراق اكبر
وتوفر القوه الناريه والقدره على المناوره
فصل الربيع حيث تخشى من هجوم الروسي
الجديد وصفته سي ان ان بانه سيكون ربيعا
وحشيا القوات الاوكرانيه تتدرب على بعد
كيلو مترات قليله من حدود بيلاروسيا وتجرى
بعض التدريبات في بلده بلده بريبيات
المهجوره منذ كارثه تشرنوبل النوويه عام
1986 هنا في هذه البلده تتدرب القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه على اقتحام المباني
وكيفيه استخدامه الشاحنات الصغيره بمدافع
رشاشه ثقيله وايضا مدافع مضاده للطائرات
كي تواجه اكثر من مئه وخمسين الف شوندير
تم تجنيدهم في الخريف الماضي وتم تدريبهم
طبعا ودمجهم في وحدات جاهزه للمعركه هنا
ايضا حسب
ذلك تعمل اوكرانيا بشكل اساسي على تحويل
جميع جيشها القائم على المعدات العسكريه
الى جيش يستخدم اسلحه غربيه متقدمه لكن
المرحله المقبله من هذه الحرب ستكون حول
الدبابات لان الدبابات القتال الغربيه
المدعومه والمدرعه ستمنح القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه مزيدا من الحركه على الارض
والحمايه من الهجوم الروسي الذي تتوقعك في
المستقبل الكلب القريب وتساعد قوات كاف
على السعاده طبعا بعض الاراضي التي سقطت
في روسيا في المرحله الماضيه كما اكد قائد
عسكري اوكراني خط التماس مشاهدينا بين
الجيشين الاوكراني والروسي في المنطقه
الجنوبيه يشهد جمودا منذ اكثر من شهر ولم
تحدث اي اشتباكات كبيره هناك بخلاف طبعا
من طاقتي خرسان في الجنوب ودنياك في الشرق
كما هو معلوم ومن الشرق مركز الاشتباكات
الحاليه
[موسيقى]
حضر المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
فيزا يمثل امرا عاجلا وضروره كبيره مضيفا
ان الوكاله الدوليه
في اوكرانيا كم اشارك روسيا لانه ادلى
باحاطه خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبيين في اوكرانيا
قال رئيس دنيا اسك المعين من روسيا ان
المسؤولين عن المديريه الوطنيه للاجئين لا
ينصحون بفتح مركز انسانيه في الوقت الحالي
مشيرا الى ان سكان سوليدار يتلقون الحمايه
والمساعده من عناصر فاتنر
توصلنا الى تفاهم مع ممثل المسؤول عن
المديريه الوطنيه
خلال هذه المرحله اضافه لذلك يدعم رجال
شركه فاجنر المدنيين هناك مدنيون لا
يريدون الذهاب الى اي مكان وهم يتلقون
المساعده
الاخبار مراسل العربيه رائد كيف هي الصوره
على الارض يعني وسير المعارك هناك وما
الجديد بموضوع الدبابات في حال حصلت
اوكرانيا على دبابات هل هناك اي اخبار عن
نقل نوعيه
بالاسلحه الروسيه
ليال مساء الخير بالفعل يعني انخفضت وتيره
القصف هنا في مقاطعه القصف الاخر
الاوكراني انخفض على المدينه
وارتفعت وتيره القصف الروسي على المدن
المتاخمه التي يتمركز فيها الجيش الاوروني
الحديث خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه عن حوالي
50 قذيفه وصاروخ فقط بينما كانت القذائف
والصواريخ تصل الى 500 صاروخ باليوم
الواحد طبعا علاقه
سوى دمار في بعض المنازل همم
المحللون هنا يرون بان هذا الانخفاض يعني
نتج عن تقدم القوات الروسيه ودفعها للجيش
الاوكراني المتاخم حيث ما زالت القوات
الروسيه تتقدم في المدن المتاخمه لمدينه
دانيسك الحديث عن مدينه
سيطره جيش الروسي على ثلثي المدينه الحديث
عن مدينه افديكا يحاول جيش الروسي اقتحام
هذه المدينه ويعني يشكل مضايقه كبيره رغم
انه لم يدخل حتى الان الى اطراف المدينه
بل وعلى العكس هناك عوده ومحاولات سيطره
لجيش الاوكراني على بعض النقاط التي كان
يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي سابقا
المحور بشكل عام القوات الخاصه قوات
باغينر سيطره على سوليدار كما اسلفت ظهر
الرئيس المعين او القائم باعمال مقاطعه من
قبل روسيا
ظهر في سوليدار كاشاره على سيطره الجيش
الروسي بشكل كامل على سوليدار وتتقدم
القوات الروسيه من سوليدار شمالا وجنوبا
شمالا نحو سيفرس حيث سيطرت على بلده قبل
سيرفس
وتسيطر ايضا على المحاور الشماليه نحو
باخم من اجل تطبيق وهنا تقدم ايضا في
اطراف
الجنوبيه حيث سيطرت على بلدتين وتحاول
تطويق المدينه
يعني القوات الروسيه تحاول تطويق المدينه
من ناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه ما زالت مدينه
دانيت كيا الاكثر سخونه بينما تشهد زبروجه
ايضا تقدم للقوات الروسيه من الناحيه
الجنوبيه وسيطرتها على بعض البلدات منهارخ
حيث بدات القوات الروسيه بتاسيس قواعد
عسكريه على اطراف المقاطعه 10 كيلومترات
واكثر دخلت قوات الروسيه في المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوروني ما زالت
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول العوده عن طريق
الخط السريع عن طريق السريع ما بين
المقاطعه خارج
وتقول الدفاع الروسيه بانها تنحي كل
القوات التي تتقدم وتقصف في محور خرسون
القوات الاوكرانيه بالفعل المعارك شائكه
يعني انا افهم انا ربما المتلقي لا يفهم
كل التفاصيل لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم
ايضا تحاول التقدم في محور خرسون وتحاول
الوصول الى فتى النهر الشماليه من اجل
التقدم نحو الضفه الجنوبيه التي انتقل
اليها الجيش الروسي هناك تقدم كبير للقوات
الروسيه في محاور مختلفه
رائد يعني انتهى الوقت طبعا خارطه المعارك
معقده نوعا ما بسبب التقدم وصدى الهجمات
بين الطرفين او بين روسيا واوكرانيا شكرا
لك رائد الاخضر وراسل العربيه حدثنا من
دنياك
نبقى في اوكرانيا حيث اكد وزير خارجيات
اوكرانيا ديميتر كوليبا على ان بلاده
بحاجه الى اتخاذ خطوات جريئه وحاسمه
لتامين انتصارها خلال العام الجاري واضاف
الوزير الاوكرانيه انه سيبحث في مجلس
العلاقات الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
عضويه بلاده في الاتحاد والمساعدات
العسكريه والدبابات وموضوع العقوبات ضد
روسيا بالاضافه الى صناعات الصواريخ
والمجال النووي
قبل ذلك كشف الدراسه عسكريه عن نقص كبير
في مخزون السلاح الامريكيه بسبب اوكرانيا
الدراسه التي نشرتها ووصفه جورنال ذكرت ان
اوكرانيا استهلا كانت مخزون سبع سنوات من
انتاج امريكا لصواريخ جافيل واشارت
الدراسه لان مخزون السلاح الامريكيه
الحالي غير كافن في وقت الحمل وانا
الولايات المتحده ستعاني من مشكلات
الذخيره اذا واجهت الصين عسكريا خليفه
لم يعد الغرب يخشى من فوزي اوكرانيا على
روسيا في الحرب لان احتمال استخدام موسكو
للنووي قضاء له وهو ما كان يخشاها الغرب
وفقا ما كشفه موقع
1945 الامريكي الامر الذي دفع بالغرب على
راسهم امريكا الى تغيير استراتيجيات دعم
اوكرانيا هذا الامر بدا واضحا من خلال
اجتماع وزراء دفاع من نحو 50 دوله في
قاعده امريكيه في غرب المانيا بعد ما زود
الاجتماع اوكرانيا باسلحه هجوميه ثقيله
وبعده يكفي الانصاريها في الحرب لا بل حتى
استعاده القلب رغم رفض رفض برلين طبعا
بارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا والجده بينها
وبين وارسو بذات الخصوص ويعتقد الخبراء
بحسب الموقع الامريكي ان استخدام موسكو
النووي اصبحيلا لان الصين والهند لم
تدعمها هذه الخطوه وانا الحظر الاقتصاديه
العالمي وضيق كثيرا على موسكو ورفعه عنها
يبقى بيده
الحرب في اوكرانيا مستعره توازيها حرب
اخرى بين قاده اوروبا في خضم معركه ايراده
الجدل والاتهامات المواجهه لبرلين
بالتقاعس عن دعم كيف على منسوبها بين
الحلفاء الغربيين المانيا في الاتهامات
تاره وتقول انها ليست حجره عثره في طريق
تزويد اوكرانيا بالعتاد
لكن اذا طلب منا فلن نقف في الطريق
الدبابات المطلوبه ليس للتجول في الشارع
ليدافع الاوكرانيون عن انفسهم افهموا مدى
اهميته هذه الدبابات وندرك ذلك تماما لهذا
السبب نحن مع جميع شركائنا في عمليه
المشاورات
وتاره اخرى تدعو الى التحلي بالصبر بشان
قرار ارسال دبابات اليو بارك سباي الى
الجيش الاوكراني فمصلحه برلين تتمثل في
اتخاذ القرار بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر عليها
يقول وزير الدفاع الالماني
تردد برلين دفع بولندا الى الاعلان عن
تشكيل تحالف يضم البلدان التي تملك دبابات
اليو بارك والمستعده لتقديمها الى كاف
منتقده المانيا على اضاعه الوقت
الى اوكرانيا وحتى لو لم نحصل على هذه
الموافقه سنستمر في تسليم دباباتنا مع
الاخرين الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
والتطورات تاتي في وقت تعمل فيه المانيا
على حساب كل المعادلات وعدم التورث في حرب
مباشره مع روسيا الغاضبه تقارير ذكرت
النبرلين لن ترسل دبابات الى اوكرانيا الا
اذا فعلت واشنطن الامر نفسه
بلال البوجدين العربيه
للحديث عن اخر تطورات هذا الموضوع
مراسله العربيه رغده يعني الجدل القائم
حول تسليم اكياف دبابات ليوبار بعد ما
فرمت المانيا هذا الموضوع وكيف سترد على
موضوع تشكيل يعني الدول الاوروبيه همم
تحالف لسد الصغرى الالمانيه بهذا الموضوع
اولا يعني دعيني ابدا بالقول بانه همم
امين عام النيته سيكون هنا في برلين يوم
غد ويلتق بوزير الدفاع الالماني اا بطبيعه
الحال هذه النقطه مساله دبابات لوبرد
اثنين ستكون على راس البحث بين الرجلين
ولكن حتى الان لا يبدو بانه هناك قرار من
طرف الحكومه الالمانيه او تحديدا من طرف
المستشار الالماني الذي يبدو انه القرار
يعني بكامله هو بيده لانه الضغوطات ليال
لا تخرج فقط عن حلفاء المانيا الغربيين
الولايات المتحده وبولندا وغيره من الدول
الغربيه وبريطانيا كذلك ولكن ايضا من داخل
الائتلاف الحاكم هناك انتقادات شديده
اللهجه من داخل الحكومه الاحتلاف الحكومي
من حزب الخضر واحسب الليبراليين همم الحزب
الاشتراك الذي هو غير اساس الحكومه ودعوات
له
خطوه باتجاه تقسيم همم تقسيم اوروبا كما
قالت
يبقى في لجنه الدفاع في البندس لا تنتمي
للحزب الليبرالي لذلك هذه الضغوط تتزايد
من اكثر من جبهه من عام من الناتو من
الدول الغربيه وايضا من داخل الحكومه حتى
الان ليس هناك طلب رسمي من اي دوله لا من
بولندا ولا من اي دوله اخرى همم للحكومه
الالمانيه لكي تاخذ يعني اذن بارسال هذه
الدبابات الى همم الى اوكرانيا ولكن
الحكومه الاوكرانيه وضعت اذنا او طلبت
اذنا من الحكومه الالمانيه في مارس الماضي
بعد بضعه ايام على بدء الحرب همم طلبت
اليها ان تسمح بارسال همم هذه الدبابات
حتى ليس من الطراز الاجداد وهذه الورقه ما
زالت لدى مكتب المستشار ولم يقر فيها ولم
يعطي بعد اي موافقه من عدمه لذلك حتى ولو
وصلت يعني هذا الطلب وصل الى مقر
المستشاريه من غير الواضح ايضا بعد كم
سيستغرق هذا همم كم ستستغرق المهله لي
يعني بحث قانونيا همم واعطاء الاذن او
يعني عدم اعطاء الاذن همم الحكومه ووزير
الدفاع ايضا يرفضان اعطائها الزمنيه
ويقلان فقط بانه همم بيمشيان بحسب القمر
شكرا لك يا راغده اذا بانتظار يعني ايش
الاخرى بالعقود القانونيه
الارسال كان ضعيف
كنت اقول بانه كان هناك كلام من المستشار
الالماني بانه يتوقع من بولندا والدول
الاخرى التي ابدت استعداد بارسال هذه
الدبابات بان تلتزم بقانونيه العقود
الموقعه مع شركه الاسلحه الالمانيه التي
تنص على ضروره اخذ الاذن من الحكومه
الالمانيه قبل ان ترسل هذه الدبابات الى
دوله ثالثه هنا نتحدث عن اوكرانيا لذلك
هناك نوع من التحذير من قبل ايضا لهذه
الدول الاوروبيه بان لا تخطوا خطوه همم
ربما من دون موافقتها تعليميه بانه كانت
هناك ايضا تصريحات متضاربه داخل الحكومه
الالمانيه سمعنا من وزير الخارجيه تقول
بانه الحكومه الالمانيه لن تعرق الاولاني
تمنع احد من ارسال هذه الدبابات ولكن يعني
اليوم عادت وامتنعت عن تكرار هذه الجمله
ويبدو انها عاده تربيه خط المستشار
الالماني الذي ماذا لا يتمحن لاعطاء
القراره شكرا لك
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد توقف لاكثر من عام المحقق العدليه
يستانف التحقيقات في انفجار مرفا بيروت
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عقوبه الاوروبيه واخرى
امريكيه على كيانات وشخصيات ايرانيه
بمقدمها الحرس الثوري حيث اعلنت الخزانه
الامريكيه فرد عقوبات جديده على اشخاص
ومؤسسات ايرانيه مرتبطه بقمع المحتاجين
بدوره تعليقا على العقوبات الاوروبيه
الجديده على ايران قال رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي ان هذه العقوبات تبرهن على ان
التكتل لن يقف مكتوب في الايدي امام
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان هناك واما مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبيل
اضافه الى ان ادراج كيان ايرانيه على
قوائم الارهاب سيحتاج الى قرار قضائي كشرت
اولي لادراش الكيانات في قوائم العقوبات
اما وزيره خارجيه المانيا فقالت انها
عمليه ادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه على
قائمه الارهاب يحتاج لمزيد من المناقشات
حذر وزير الخارجيه النمسا من ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا يريد اي السباق تسلح في
المنطقه في الوقت الذي تتحرك فيه ايران
بالاتجاه الخاطئ وترسل المسيارات والمعدات
الحربيه الى روسيا مضيفا انا الاتحاد
الاوروبي ادرج 37 شخصا وكيانا ايرانيا
جديدا على قائمته للعقوبات فل السماء
بسرعه كبيره في الاتجاه الخاطئ من خلال
شحنه الطائره بدون طيار والمعدات الحربيه
الى روسيا وما تقوم به من قمع لشعبها لذا
فان العقوبات ضروريه
سيتم وضعه 37 شخصا وكيا جديدا على قائمه
عقوبه الاتحاد الاوروبي وستستمر هذه
الاجراءات علينا مواصله الضغط طالما ان
ايران تشارك بشكل غير مباشر في جرائم
الحرب وترسل طائره بدون طيار وربما صواريخ
الى روسيا
ليست طويله سيتمكن النظام الايراني من
الحصول على سلاح النووي واسرائيل تهدد
بعمل عسكري كحل اخير لردعي قدرات طهران
النوويه وفقه ما كشفته صحيفه البريطانيه
طهران تعملوا على تخصيب مخزوناتها من
اليورانيوم كي تصل الى عتبه 90% وهو
المستوى المطلوب لانشاء راس حربي نووي
يمكن وضعه في صاروخ بالسيسي تقول هنا
الصحيفه البريطانيه الوصول مشاهدينا الى
سلاح النوويه السابق ثمانيه عشر شهرا
لانشاء نظام توصيل فعال وايران قضت معظم
تلك المده وامامها فقط اسابيع وفقه خبراء
غربيين الامر الذي سيجبر الغرب واللاعبين
الاقليميين على اعاده تقييم خياراتهم
حتى الان قام النظام الايراني بتخصيب 75
كيلوغرام من اليورانيوم حتى اي وصل الى
حدود 60 فئه مما يكفي طبعا لصنع قنبله
نوويه
ولتحييد قدرات ايران النوويه هددت اسرائيل
مشاهدينا بانها ستشن عملا عسكريا كحل اخير
ضد طهران حتى ولو قامت به بمفردها من دون
طعم طبعا دعم الحلفاء الضربات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه يجب ان تنفذ قريبا نظرا لقرب
تواصل طهران الى العتبه النوويه حيث يمكن
لايران دفن هذه المواد على عمق 60 متر تحت
الارض في مصنع فرده للتخصيب بالقرب كما
اشار طبعا الصحيفه الامريكيه ومن خلال
تسليح برنامجها النووي تعتقدران بانها
ستعزز قوتها الاقليميه والدوليه لفرض
شروطها دوليا مما يصعب طبعا الاطاحه او
تغيير النظام الايراني
مشاهدينا من القدس دكتور
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه دكتور
مصري يعني اليوم العين على نتانيا واذا ما
كان سيخطى خطوه سلفيه
بموضوع النووي العراقي
والنووي
السوري فبالتالي هل ممكن ان يذهب الى هذه
الخطوه بالرغم يعني طبعا من عدم الدعم
الامريكي بهذه الموضوع واعتبار بعض
موجود بالمؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
بانها هكذا خطوه فرديه هي همم عدم محسوب
العقبات بالمرحله المقبله
شوكولاته مع الاستضافه اساسي كريمه
وتحياتي للجميع اولا المقفل الاسرائيلي
ثابت ما يتعلق بهذا الامر اسرائيل مستعده
للتدخل العسكري في العمق الايراني وما صدر
عن عسكريين السابقين ورجال مخابرات سابقين
في اسرائيل لا يمثلوا على الاطلاق على
المؤسسه الامنيه داخل اسرائيل
عام السياسي السلطه في اسرائيل
مؤسسه
لا يعني كل ما صدر من تصريحات هي من
مسؤولين سابقين وبالتالي انا لا اعتقد ان
هذا قيمه كبيره فيما تعود على المساله
ان هناك
دعمك او انه اذا لم تحصل على الضوء الاخضر
امريكي كيف هذا الكلام اذا كانت اسرائيل
صرفت 5 مليارات شكل مليار ونصف
الملياردولار لشراء اسلحه ومعدات ومروحيات
ضخمه وقنابل جميع هذه المعدات
من الولايات المتحده
هنا هذه وجهه النظر هذه تاتي من مبدا تفرد
اليوم الولايات المتحده شرقا وتفردا للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وطبعا هناك العديد من
المخاطر بحال توجيه هذه الضربه نتحدث على
احتماليه فتح حزب الله لجبهه الشمال من
سوريا ومن جنوب لبنان نتحدث عن يعني
احتماليات عده موجوده ودراسات وليست
بالبعيده عن الاداره الاسرائيليه
انا لا اتفق مع هذا التقييم انا اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده قد قعدت اكثر من ضوء
اخضر لاسرائيل اسرائيل اشترت جميع الاسلحه
من الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
تعهدت على لسان رئيسها وبلغه انجليزيه
وكذلك على لسان وزير خارجيتها في زيارته
الاخيره الى اورشليم القدس في العام
الفائز قال بشكل واضح وصريح ان الولايات
المتحده تتعهد بالدفاع عن اسرائيل في حين
تعرضت ضربه انتقاميه من قبل النظام
الايراني في السياق
في الداخل الايراني ان هناك يعني الانغماس
وانخراط امريكي وتوارد امريكي واضح ان
نتحدث عن خطوه جديه اسرائيليه بهذا
الموضوع ام انه تهديد فقط
لا يوجد
النظام الايراني لديها اليوم وهو اصبح
في واضح النهار ان لديه برنامج وطبع عسكري
صرح بهذا نحن قلنا هذا الكلام مرارا
وتكرار على مدى سنوات العالم لم يصدق
ونظام الايراني كان ينكر ويقول ان لديه
فتوى تحريم النووي العسكري وحتى ظهر علينا
كمال خرازي في سبعه عشر من يوليو تموز على
قناه الجزيره وقال ان النظام يخسر بستين
بالمائه قدره ان يخلص البلاد التسعين
بالماء واليوم الحديث عن بدايه اي ان نحن
في في عمليه برنامج لتابعه
استاذتي النظام اولا يمارس الارهاب ان
يحصل على سلاح نووي ثانيا نظام عضو في
المعاهده لعدم الانتشار لانه هذا يهدد
نظام عدم الانتشار دوله هذا تكون سابقه
تاريخيا دوله عضو في نظام عدم الانتشار
واقعه على مؤهلات العام 70 همم هذا هو
واضح تصنع قنبله ذريه والنقطه الاخيره
استاذه كريمه انه اسرائيل لن تخطر العالم
بموعد همم
دكتور مصري بهذه النقطه تحديدا بمنطق
توازن العلاقات الخارجيه امتلاك ايران
للنووي اليوم
يعني سيحدث عدم توازن بالقوه الخارجيه
وتحديدا العسكريه منها بين طهران ودول
المنطقه اليوم الخيار العسكري المطروح
بجديه على الطاوله هل سيعيد هذا التواصل
وباختصار لو سمحت
اليوم بنظام ايراني باتي يهدد جميع الدول
المنطقه بدون استثناء وليس لديه اي حديث
الا اذا اعتبرنا نظام الاسد يمثل سوريا
فقط مجرد ميليشيات زيول في جميع الدول
تهدد امن المنطقه ولا تنسى الى الحكومات
المانيه في الدول الالمانيه وبالتالي
استاذتي الكريم بدون نظام يهدد معنى نووي
سوف يكون التهديد اضعاف وانا اعتقد انه
هناك او موفق كامل في المنطقه من الدول
العربيه ودول غير العربيه نووي ايراني هذا
سوف معناها ان هو يكرس الهيمنه الايرانيه
على دول عربيه والشرق الاوسط شكرا
على علوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه على
هذه المداخله
نبقى في ايران لكن في ملف الاحتجاجات حيث
اوقفت سلطات الايرانيه ثلاث صحفيات عملنا
لصالح مؤسسات محليه على اثر الاحتجاجات
التي تشهدها البلاد منذ وفاه ماسه امينه
بحسب ما افادت جمعيه الصحفيين في طهران
وعوردت الجمعيه عن الصحابيات الثلاثهن
ملكه هاشميه وسعيده
ومهنوش زراعي وتعاد شافعي صحفيه مستقله
وروائيه بينما تعمل زراعي لصالح وكالات
انباء محسوبه على التيار الاصلاحي في حين
تعمل الهاشمي لصالح وكاله شهر
تداول نشطاء ايرانيون مقطعا مصورا يظهر
يظهر فيه عناصر امن بلباس مدني يعتدون على
فتاتين ويقومون باعتقالهم
[موسيقى]
على فتاه في الشارع حيث قام بركلها وضربها
بالبندقيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في تطور القضائي في لبنان عاد المحقق
العدلي في ملف انفجار مرفا بيروت القاضي
طارق البيطار الى مهمته المعلقه منذ سنه
نتيجه طلبات الرد المقدمه من مده عليهم
المدير العام الامن العام عباس ابراهيم
ومدير عام امن الدوله اللواء طوني خليفه
[موسيقى]
الى العراق وبالتزامل مع اعفاءات رئيس
الحكومه محمد شياع السوداني لمسؤولين في
سوق المال في يوصل الدينار العراقي
انخفاضه امام الدولار الامريكي ليسجل سعر
الصرف مقابل الدينار مستويات غير مسبوقه
منذ عام 2004 المراقبون يرجعون سبب انخفاض
الدينار لاسباب عده منها تهريب الاموال
للخارج والاجراءات الاخيره التي اتخذتها
واشنطن لمنع تحويل الدولارات من العراق
الى ايران طبعا بدوره امهل السوداني
للمحافظه الجديده البنك ثلاثه اشهر فقط
لاعاده الامور الى مصابها او سيلقى مصير
سلفه وفقا طبعا لمصادر عراقيه
نحذر من يحاول استغلال الازمه واللعب على
اوجاع الناس واحتياجاتهم
لم يرتفع سعر صرف نتيجه قرار حكومي انما
لان هناك من استغل الظروف الوقتيه
والاضطراب في الاسواق التي لم تالف بعده
تعامل مع الخطوات والاليات المصرفيه
الجديده التي ستحافظ على اموال الشعب وهي
خطوه مهمه على طريق الاصلاح الاقتصادي
ونؤكد هنا
على اولويه مكافحه جائحه الفساد فلا يمكن
لاي جهد ان يتكلم بالنجاح طالما بقيت هذه
الجائحه قادره على الانتقال والانتشار في
جسد الدوله
النشاط الحقوقي استاذ العلوم
انه منذ عام 2005 وموضوع تهريب الاموال من
العراق وتبييض الاموال وتعريبه الى النظام
في طهران ومن ثم ايضا الى الى دمشق موجوده
ولكنها يعني كانت بوتيره اوسع واكبر في
الفتره الماضيه بسبب الضغط على هذين
النظامين نتيجه العقوبات الدوليه اليوم
عدم امتثال همم العراق لقرارات الفدرالي
الامريكي وايضا ال- يعني وجود هذا التعريف
بكميات كبيره الى اي ماده ادى الى تؤذيه
همم الدينار العراقي والواقع الاقتصادي
العراقي
على ما يبدو ان الصوره تتقطع والارسال
ضعيف او دكتور مهند ساعود اليك فورا جهود
الاتصال مجددا المشاهدين سانتقل الى هذا
التقرير واعود من بعده
الجمله هي الاكثر تداولا هنا في الاسواق
العراقيه
حيث لا يكاد يمر الا وارتفع معه سعر الصرف
وتزايدت المخاوف من تكرار سيناريو ينهيار
العمله اللبنانيه في العراق
في الاداره العراقيه التعاون مع الفدرالي
الامريكي لحل الازمه لان المتضرر صراحه
التهاجره الضرر الفقير الضرر المستهلك
الضرر
كل
الامور في بغداد الان واقفه بسبب ارتفاع
الدولار الغير طبيعي
دولار تسبب لهم بمشاكل ماليه
كلها اللحوم عندنا الدجاج كله تركي ايراني
كله صاعد يعني كله بالدولار
واحنا جاي نعيش بازمه والله الي يستر من
القادم انه يعني مثل الدول الجوار مثلا
لبنان شلون صار
الدولار الدولار
كنت بصالح البنك المركزي وبصالح الاقتصاد
لتوصيل اكثر القرار حضيه بغطاء كامل من
تلاف اداره الدوله ومن الاطار التنسيقي
واا تقديري اي الخطوات التي اتخذت الحكومه
خطوات جريئه وقويه وفاعله
وستؤثر بشكل سريع همم يعني على مستوى
السوق في اعاده التوازن الى سعر العمله
القديمه
وخسارته نحو عشره بالمئه من قيمه الدينار
شكل تحديا حقيقيا لحكومه السودان لانه يمص
الطبقات الفقيره بشكل مباشر الامر الذي
ينذر بتحركات شعبيه على مستوى الشارع اذا
ما استمرت قيمه الدولار في الصعود امام
الدينار بالتسامح مع اقاله محافظ البنك
المركزي شهده الاسواق الم انخفاضا نسبيا
في اسعار صرف الدولار امام الدينار لكن
يبقى سؤال هنا هل سيستمر هذا الانخفاض ام
سيكون بشكل مؤقت سامر الكبيسي العربيه
بغداد
مشاهدينا اعود الى اربيل والدكتور مهند
الجنابي الناشط الحقوقي واستاذ العلوم
السياسيه دكتور مهند استمعت الى هذا
التقرير وكنت قد طرحت سؤال عن موضوع
الاجراءات وكل يعني ما يحيط بهذا الملف
تفضل
نعم
استاذ المشاهدين اعتقد بانه الازمه
الحاصله الان في العراق ربما لا ترتبط
بشكل مباشر بالسياسه النقديه صحيح انه
البنك المركزي هو المسؤول عن تداول العمله
وعن الحفاظ على استقرار سعر صرف الدولار
امام الدينار العراقي لكن نتصور بانه
المساله والازمه هي اعمق من السياسه
النقديه التي يتبعها البنك المركزي همم
المشكله هي مشكله مزمنه مشكله مستعصيه على
السياسه العامه للدوله وعلى السياسه
الماليه وشخص رئيس الوزراء هذا اليوم في
مناسبات عند بانه الفساد والمضاربه وحتى
همم نعلم جميعا بانه عمليه همم تحويل هذه
الاموال والمصار غير مجازه او التي تعمل
خارج الضوابط هي المتسببه بها كذا همم
يعني عمليات والتي كلها تندرج تحت النفوذ
الاقليمي واا يعني جماعات ايران وسياسه
ايران في العراق بالتالي يتصور بانه هكذا
اجراء همم قد يرتبط وقتيا في انخفاض سعر
صرف الدين همم صرف امام الدينار العراقي
لكن القضيه بتصور انها بحاجه الى اجراءات
معززه على سبيل المثال محاربه الفساد ضبط
الحدود محاربه من يسطو على الكتله النقديه
الدوليه في الاسواق العراقيه والتي يبيعها
البنك المركزي بشكل يومي اعتقد بانها تاتي
على راس اولويات الحكومه للحفاظ على همم
الحاله او استعاده همم قيمه الدينار
العراقي كما كان قبل الازمه وما ذكرتموه
في تقريركم بانه سيد رئيس الوزراء منح
المحافظ الجديد ثلاثه اشهر هذا مؤشر على
انه هذه الازمه قد لا تستقر بشكل اني خلال
اسبوع او اسبوعين همم السقف الزمن الذي
وضعه رئيس الوزراء اعتقد بانه هذه الازمه
قد تمتد الى شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر حتى
تستطيع الحكومه ان تقوم باجراءاتها في دعم
السياسه النقديه هل تستطيع الحكومه انا
اعتقد بانه الاجراءات حتى الان ربما لا
تبشر بخير او لم تتقدم خطوات الى هذا
يتوقف على قادم الايام وعلى ما همم يعني
يمكن حكومه السوداني من
فكر تباطها عن الضغوطات التي تتعرض لها في
هذه المساله فضلا عن ذلك طبيعه الامتثال
الى النظام المالي المصرفي الدولي
واستجابه العراق لهذا تحديات
الدولي خصوصا انه منذ ان شارك يعني
الامريكيين بتاسيس البنك المركزي العراقي
الدولار يعتبر العمله الاساسيه اليوم بضل
الضغوط التي يواجهها ايضا رئيس الوزراء
بما انه محسوب على الطرف معين هذه الضغوط
همم يعني هل سيستطيع ان يقوم باجراءات
جذريه للحد من تهريب الدولار الى الخارج
هذه مشكله صراحه استاذ العيال يعني اذا
عدنا اليوم امس يوم امس كان هنالك اجتماع
لقاعده الاطار التنسيقي وبحضور السيد رئيس
الوزراء وهذا اليوم صدر القرار باعفاء
المحافظ السابق وتعيين السيد العلاق
كمحافظ البنك المركزي وبالتالي اتصور بانه
بعد اجتماع يوم امس قد يكون هذا التعيين
جابت تاثير من قوى الاطار التنسيقي نحن
الان بحاجه الى شفافيه عاليه في ما يتعلق
باجراءات البنك المركزي هل ستعود قيمه
الدينار كما وعد المحافظ الجديد ووعد رئيس
الحكومه بناءا على سياسات تحافظ بشكل كامل
وتمتثل بشكل كامل ام انها ستكون عوده خارج
اطار الامتثال اي بمعنى ضغط المزيد من
الدولار لبعض الجهات المشبوهه او المدرجه
ضمن العقوبات الامريكيه هذه بتصوري بانها
همم عمليه شفافيه يجب ان تكون واضحه كي
نعرف اين ستؤول الامور فيما يتعلق بنظام
المالي الاسره في العراق العراقي هذه
المسؤوليات والتدخل السياسي يتصور انه كان
حاضرا في تعيين المحافظه الجديد لكن بكل
تاكيد الحكومه هي تتحمل مسؤوليه ويعني
محاوله تجنيب اجراءاتها التدخلات السياسيه
يقع على عاتق رئيس الوزراء وبالتالي هو
سيكون مسؤول امام الشعب العراقي وحتى امام
البرلمان وكل من يحاول ان يضع الحكومه
انه هناك يعني البعضوا الى منحه ضغوط
امريكيه لافشال وبشارع للهروب من المشكله
الاساسيه ع- شكرا لك يا دكتور مهند
نشاط الحقوقي استاذ العلوم السياسيه على
هذه المداخله
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
بعد اكتشاف المزيد منها مشرعون امريكيون
يصفون وثائق بايدن السريه بالفضيحه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
حركه طالبان بحق النساء تصر عشرات الفتيات
على استكمال
رغم الحظر المفروض مؤخرا وذلك
تتجمع عشرات الفتيات الافغانيات يوميا في
منازل في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول لتلقي
التعليميه تلقينا مواد عده منها اللغه
الانجليزيه والرياضيات والعلوم وتحويه تلك
المدارس في كابول وحده نحو 150 طالبه وهو
مشجع فتيات اخريات ومعلومات جامعيات الى
اتخاذ ذات الخطوه في مدن افغانيه اخرى وهو
طبعا ما يعد الذاكره مدارس سريه مشابهه
كانت تعلم الفتيات في عهد الطالبان بين
عام
1996 و 2000 واحد
[موسيقى]
هذا وقالت منظمه الامم المتحده للتربيه
والثقافه والعلوم والناسكو ان المدير
العمل المنظمه قررت تخصيص اليوم الدولي
للتعليم هذا العام والذي يوافق في الرابع
والعشرين من يناير للفتيات والنساء
الافغانيات واضافت المنظمه انه بمناسبه
اليوم الدولي للتعليم
في مقر الامم المتحده وتخصص حلقه النقاش
الاولى لتعليم الفتيات والنساء في
افغانستان هذا وجدت المنظمه الامميه
دعوتها لاستعاده الافغانيات حقهن الاساسي
في التعليم على الفور
افغانستان بلد تحكمه حركه طالبان بقوه
السلاح وحكم يقول لا مكان للنساء
والفتيات عن الحياه العامه
وحرمتهن من حقوقهن الاساسيه احدها الحق في
التعليم الا ان الافغانيات دافعنا عنه
بسلاح المدارس السريه في كل صباح باحد
افقر احياء العاصمه كابول تجتمع فتيات في
منزل للدراسه هو جزء من شبكه من ثمان
مدارس في خمس مدن تقدم خدماتها سرا
وبالمجان تدعمها منظمه
في المناطق الشديده التاثر بحضر مدارس
البنات
على الحكم في افغانستان عام 2021 الا ان
هناك ما يقرب من 250 امراه تاثرنا بحذر
طالبان للتعليم في التسعينات هنا انفسهن
بتنايب حثنا عنهم مجددا في المدارس السريه
رغم الخطر الذي يواجه المعلمات طالبات الا
انهن يتمسكن بالتعليم المتحديات احتمال
التعرض للاعتقال والقتل
ويتحايلنا على اعين عناصر الحركه باخفاء
ادوات التعليم وسلك طرق طويله ومختلفه
نترك كتبنا في المنزل وفي الفصل اذا كان
لدينا واجب منزلي نكتبه على قطعه من الورق
بقلمنا ونضعه في جيبنا
العائق الوحيد امام المدارس السريه ليس
سهلا اذ ان سريتها ثانيه عدم حصول
الطالبات على شهادات رسميه وتدقنا قسم خوف
ظهور جيل من الفتيات عشنا حاضرا وسط الحرب
والقمع
وبانتظارهن مستقبل رائع روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايبين كابل
باريس تو حكيم الكاتبه والناشطه استاذه
حكيم يعني قمع الحق بالمعرفه يدفع اليوم
النساء الافغانيات الى سرقه هذه المعرفه
هل تخافون من حمله اعتقال واسعه واجراءات
قمعيه في المرحله المقبله
عشان الشنطه
في وجهه ان طالبان الذين يقفون ضد امام كل
ابواب المدارس والجامعات
بيحملون الاتحاد صغيره والكبيره ولا
يسمحون لاي فتاه بدخول المدرسه هو بشكل
اساسي فان التعليم مركز التعليم كلها حضرت
بعد ان استولى طالبان على السلطه
ولكن هذا هو حق من حقوق من الاساسيات
واليوم بينما ان عمله
كان ذلك
بالشجاعه المجيء الى مدارس
تعلم ان افغانستان سيكون مستقبلها مظلم
يعني نساء افغانستان
قاومنا منذ زمن كل محاولات القمح يعني
اخذنا سلبنا الحقوق صلبه اليوم يعني الذين
الحقوق التي سلبها طبعا همم طالبان عبر
السنوات الماضيه اليوم ما هي الرساله التي
توجهها للمجتمع الدولي خصوصا ان الامم
المتحده سيكون العنوان همم كما اعلن قبل
قليل سيكون العنوان نساء طالبان بالجلسه
المقبله
النساء افغانستان عفوا
مجموعه
من الحوارات والخطاباتي
وضعيه الكريمات على احداث صغيره
وليقولوا بانهم يعملون معنا اذا ما اراد
العمل معنا به حقا من المنظمات الدوليه
والدول الاسلاميه ان تتحدى طالبان
يجب ان يعرف بان الشعب الافغاني وخاصه
المره الافغانيه لا تقف ضد الشريعه الله
نحن لسنا ضد الحجاب ولسنا ضد كافه
التعليمه الاسلاميه
ولا يجب ان يتوسل الحصول عليه او حتى
اتمنى انه اهلا به
الوسائل التي يمكن اليوم للمجتمع الدولي
ان يضغط فيها على طالبان يعني بكل موضوع
الحقوق التي يمارسها او الاضطهاد الذي
يمارسه على النساء في افغانستان
ذهاب الى المدارس
ما الذي يفعله العالم وما الذي ينتظرون
كما نرى فان همم منها
بعرف بعرف
حق التعليم والعمل للمراه والفتيات في
افغانستان فقط
وهو ان تستخدمها افغانستان كمل هذا امن
للارهابيين والشده الارهاب
فهل العالمي ينتظروا احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر اخرى لكي يتصرف
الاسلاميه
والحديث والقران الشريف نفسه
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى موضوع التهديد
النووي الايراني والملف الاسرائيلي
نفانيفه يقول ايران تشكل خطرا على العالم
والمنطقه عبر تطويرها سلاحا نوويا اذا كان
هذا التصريح لنتنياه بذل كل الحديث عن
ضربه حقيقيه ممكن ان توجهها اسرائيل
لطهران
لم يعد ملف وثائق بعيد الناصريه امرا
عاديا او اقل فضيحه من تلك التي سبقها به
سلفه دونالد ترامب وفقا لاوصان صحفيه
وسياسيه في الولايات المتحده طبعا اذا انا
الملف بدا ياخذ منعطفا خطيرا كون الملفات
المكتشفه بدات تزداد كمياتها واعدادها لبن
من بينها ملفات خطيره تتعلق باسرار الدوله
الامريكيه وهو ما عرض الانتقادات لاذعه من
المتابعين الامريكيين في الكونغرس من
الحسبين الجمهوري يوديموقراطي معتبرينها
فضيحه من العيار الثقيل بالرغم من تقليل
بايضا من اهميه هذه القضيه معظم ما يعود
الى عهده باراك اوباما او العهد اوباما
عندما كان بيضا نائبا للرئيس
[موسيقى]
ازمه تصحيح الموظفين في قطاع التكنولوجيا
ما زالت مستمره ويبقى السؤال ما الذي حل
بهذا القطاع حتى وصل الى هذا الحد من
تراجع الارباح واللجوء الى تخفيض عدد
الموظفين وتسريحهم يقول خبراء التكنولوجيا
ان قطاع التكنولوجيا شهد طفره ارباح
خلالها انتشار فايروس كورونا لان بعد
الاغلاق في دول العالم لجا الموظفون الى
العمل عن بعد وكانت العائلات تؤمن
مشترياتها من خلال متاجر الانترنت هذا
فضلا طبعا عن النمو في شركات الالعاب
والافلام على الانترنت اما امام هذا
الواقع طبعا مشاهدينا لاجيء لجات شركات
تكنولوجيا عده الى التوسع وساده عدد
الموظفين كي تلاقي ارتفاع الطلب وزياده
الارباح ولكن بعد انحار كورونا حصلت ما في
هذا القطع ولم يعد الطلب على التكنولوجيا
كما كان في العام 2020 ما غير المعدلات
برماتها عوامل اخرى طبعا تضاف ادت الى ضرب
قطاع التكنولوجيا مثل ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده والتضخم والمخاوف من الركوب
العالم الاقتصادي كل هذه الامور ساهمت
بتراجع الاعلانات طبعا وانفاق المستهلكين
ماثر على ارباح شركات التكنولوجيا واسعار
الاسهم خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه اعلنت
كبريات شركات التكنولوجيا مثل امازون
وجوجل مايكروسوفت عن خطط لتسريح اكثر من
50,000 موظف وهو واقع معكس للاشهر الاولى
من الوباء
[موسيقى]
كشفت مصادر الكرديه لمراس العربيه انا
تركيا قطعت نحو مصر مياه نهر الفرات عن
سوريا محضره من حدوث كارثه انسانيه بحلول
الصيف مع فقدان الامل بقدره امطار الشتاء
تعويض النهر بالمياه
الفرات العظيم قد لا يدوم عظيما تركيا
قطعت نصف مياهه وشتاء لم يسعف النهر بامره
كانت هنا قبل بضعه السنوات قبل ان تتراجع
كل هذه المسافه الى ادنى مستوى في تاريخ
النهر
لتنكبش الى هنا وذلك بسبب تقلص الوارد
المائي الى 200
متر مكعب في الثانيه من اصل 500 متر مكعب
متفق عليه مع تركيا
الواقع الجديد هبط بانتاج الكهرباء من
السدود الرئيسيه ودفع الاداره المحليه الى
زياده التقنيين الذي شمل ايضا مياه الري
وشرب كما فاقم المشاكل الصحيه جراء تلوث
مياه النهر
لقطع الماء حاسه من تركيا هذا غلط لازم كل
العالم
توقف معانا يعني
المسؤولون الاكراد رهنوا هذا الشتاء على
الامطار لتخزين كميات اكبر من المياه في
السدود الا ان غيابها شكل صدمه للجميع
الموسم الشتوي الجاف الثقافه ان يكون هناك
ربيع جاف علينا وصيف اييي يعني مخيف على
مجمل انتاج سدود من مياه الشرب او قنوات
او الطاقه الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
ورغم المخاطر التي تهدد حياه المليون
انسان في سوريا فقط لا تزال مشكله نهر
غائبه عن طاوله الحوار بين تركيا سوريا
والعراق كم يبدو ان الاطراف الدوليه غير
مهتمه ببساطه تحول دون وقوع الكارثه من
الرقه جمع عكاش العربيه
[موسيقى]
الغرب يعمق عقوبات على ايران بسبب القمع
وتحذيراته من اقتراب امتلاك طهران القنبله
النوويه
وفي العراق ازمه الدينار تتسبب بازمه
الثقه السوداني يمهل المحافظه الجديد
للبنك المركزي ثلاثه اشهر
المدارس السريه تتحدث طالبان الفتيات
الافغانيات يوصلن التعليم رغم الحظر
مشاهدينا الى هنا ناتي الى ختام التاسعه
لكن طبعا اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل
ليله والان الى 360 والزملاء راويه وطاهر
راويه وطاهر مساء الخير ماذا لديكم الليله
مساء الخير ليال طبعا سنتحدث عن حزمه
المساعدات الاوروبيه المنتظر وصولها الى
اكياف وكيف ستتعامل معها وسط العديد من
العراق
في العراق وهل سا- ستاتي اجراءات محمد
شيعه السوداني اكلها ام لا كوني معنا